so welcome everyone i'm michael woodford
from the department of economics here to
welcome you to an event sponsored by our
program for economic research it's a
it's a great pleasure to have Francesco
Javad see here to speak to us as many of
you know he's a professor of economics
at bocconi university in Milan which is
probably the most distinguished Italian
faculty for economics and business he's
he's been there for a long time among
other things he was the founding
director of EG ER the inner chancel
Gasperini institute for economic
research at mikoni which has done a lot
to increase the international visibility
of research there he's also research
fellow and trustee of the Center for
Economic Policy Research in London and a
research associate of the national
bureau of economic research here in the
US he is his scholarly career is much
too extensive for me to try to summarize
he has written or edited at least 16
books so far just to mention some of the
more notable things he's very well known
as an expert on exchange rate policy
exchange rate systems and especially on
fiscal policy apart from his scholarly
activities professor Javad C has been
very much involved in public service
both in Italy and in Europe to mention
some of the high points of that he was
director general of the italian treasury
between 1992 and 1994 responsible for
debt management and privatization he was
then a member of the Council of Economic
Advisers to the italian prime minister
from 1998 to 2,000 in the
the dilemma government and more recently
he was a member of the group of economic
policy advisors to the president of the
european commission from 2002 2010 he's
also plays a very important role in
europe as a public intellectual and
those of you who follow the Italian
press probably already know him as a
regular economic columnist for the
Corriere della Sera so it's a great
pleasure to to welcome Francesco Javad
see to talk to us about italy's future
on the eve of what many are expecting
maybe a historic turning point in this
upcoming election thank you Michael
thank you all for coming this cold night
so these are talk about the future of
Italy five days ahead of the elections
so I think the discussion after the talk
will be more increased the talk itself
so the torque itself is about where
Italy stands and the end some thoughts
about what what could lie ahead I want
to start with a slide which I think
gives the an overall picture what has
happened to Italian economy in the past
20 years so this is income per per
capita setting the United States at a
hundred from which you can see that back
in nineteen ninety French Italy and and
in Germany were at the same point but
then Italy which is the red line decline
Germany which is the Green Line also the
clients but that is due to the impact on
the German economy of German unification
in the 90s but then you see that early
in the past decade the trans diverge and
income per capita
Germany that now includes eastern
Germany starts rising well the one for
Italy declining and this is the concern
that has been for the past 20 years a
steady decline in in income per capita
that it is a measure that you can think
of it as very close to the real wage
that people take home so I want to do
two things first I want to start from
the short run and discuss what has
happened in Italy in the past couple of
years of the big crisis that peaked in
the summer of two thousand eleven
because this I think is a good
introduction of the longer term problem
that Italy faces today but keep this
picture in mind because we're going to
return to this to this later so that's
in deficit so where was Italy before the
financial crisis so this is the fiscal
situation of the country in 2007 and
what I wrote here fragile but not
insolvent is a description it was
fragile because when you have a high
debt to GDP ratio which at the time was
one hundred twenty percent you are very
fragile any small movement in interest
rate can you can move you out of course
but given the numbers of 2007 it was not
insolvent nominal growth was two percent
so real gross was small but positive one
percent one percent inflation the
average cost of death was relatively
moderate for a half percent model for a
country had a hundred twenty percent
debt to GDP the maturity was very long
seven years so if you if interest rate
move today before the effect entire
structure the death takes a long time to
keep that stable you would have needed a
three percent primary surplus oyes
service of the budget net of interest
rate in Italy had three and a half so it
was actually that was slowly falling
very slowly falling so it was fragile
but
but not nothing sold and then comes the
recession as fear of the financial
crisis that which hit Italy in a
particular strong way so output in 08 09
fell summing at 72 years almost seven
percent six point seven percent in the
euro area as a whole including Greece
and Spain it fell four percent so it
fell much more than view area now this
is a puzzle which I think has not been
studied and their students here were
interested to be a good case study to
understand why did the Italian economy
we remember there was no housing bubble
there were no derivatives in the banking
system if we looked at it was
financially one of the strongest
economies is real why did output fall by
much more than in countries like Spain
where different our situation was we can
not only output fell in 08 09 but then
in in 10 11 when there was this temper
recovery in the euro area output turn
positive 1 percent but still half and
the rest of the unit was 1.8 so the
recovery the fall was deeper the
recovering was was lower so what
happened that faith looking at this look
at an economy that was fragile and that
fell into this big hole markets got
worried and lost confidence and when you
lose confident any had one hundred
twenty percent that GDP ratio you can
get in trouble very fast so this would
happen to the interest rate on Italian
government bonds of various maturity
three five and ten years and this is
what happened in the some in the summer
fall of 2011 when eventually
berlusconi government gave up big as a
result of the financial crisis oh the
marginal cost of a debt went from four
and a half percent up to seven and a
half percent now we have a high that
this is a is a big trouble because at
that point when that when the average
cost of debt was lowly because the
maturity was not was lawyer rising two
two to seven percent we serve the
primary surplus Italy would have needed
to keep the dead stable was no longer
three and a half which is the situation
before the crisis but increased to
around seven eight percent of course a
lot depends on what on what grows does
so the actual numbers which were minus
one real growth and one percent
inflation meant that the primary circuit
have been eight percent it was actually
smaller than three and a half because
the recession so the dead started rising
rising a lot there was a discussion at
this point among among economists
Olivier blush are the economic advisor
of the EMF had the view that Italy had
simply shifted to a bad equilibrium so
we know in a have a high debt a shock
comes you move to a bay with equilibrium
because market lose confidence for any
reason because
it's a bad day or it's raining and you
get into into trouble and only this
point was you just have to do something
to bring back confidence and and you are
fun I think that this was not the case i
think that the loss of confidence is
because markets is so output phone they
realized that even in the turnaround in
10-11 output did not starts rising at
least as fast and the rest of the euro
area later side other places and they
they thought that with it with low
growth it would never have been able to
keep to keep the dead stable so the the
opposite if you want view to what Olivia
was saying is it's not only question of
confidence you have to convince invest
remember that half of the Italian that
the time was held abroad so it's it's a
lot its large amount of of that was not
simply a question of of bringing back
confidence or if you want the only way
to bring my confidence was to convince
those who are holding the debt that
growth would resume because without
growth it would be it was very difficult
to keep the dead the dead stable so how
what was the policy response to the to
the shock to the loss of confidence so
this is the fiscal so the fiscal plan
was half the responsibility of the
Berlusconi government maybe they almost
half so before they gave up in November
of 2011 and half the responsibility of
the following government led by the
president of my university Mario Monti
we who took over at the end of november
in 11 so they share the responsibility
of the merit of what they did so these
are the numbers they did a significant
shift in the budget the increase taxes
by three percent of gdp bringing the
average tax rate from forty six and a
half to 49 half almost half of gdp they
cut spending a bit by 0.2 so almost
nothing
because spending was cut by one percent
of GDP but the interest cost of the dead
because interest rate by then were
rising took out most of the benefit of
the of the cut in spending so overall
the thing was point to point point three
so this was a large fiscal adjustment or
three percent of GDP than over two years
in a year of recession that done on
paper to third with higher taxes
sixty-three percent with higher taxes
and about a third with lower spending
however these are the official numbers
if you look at bit behind behind the
official numbers you realize that this
one percent cut in spending is not
really was not really reduction in
spending by the government this was
mostly reduction in the transfers from
the central government to local
authorities to city regions and
provinces and most of these local
authorities reacted to the cutting in
transfer by the central government by
raising local taxi so if you do the
numbers right you realize that almost
the entire adjustment three-point-seven
percent of gdp was done one way or than
others another through higher taxes so
if you do the numbers about eighty
percent higher taxes and twenty percent
lower lower spending so this was at the
adjustment what was what was the outcome
well the multiplier was was not
favorable because you raised taxes three
percent of gdp growth in the year that
just closed was minus 2.2 so we went
from zero in 2011 0 point plus 0.2 to
minus 2.2 implied contemporaneous
multipliers with instantaneous
multiplying the same ear was about point
8 the IMF forecast for this year is
another year of recession
minus one which imply that the two-year
multiplies with the effect on output of
the three percent increase in in the
revenue or over a year is about is about
one now of course because the economy
was it was and his collapsing that is
rising so it started from 120 this it
will end the year this year at 126 now
this it depend part of the 126 is due to
the money that Italy has contributed to
the bailout of Greece so if you take
that out that only goes to 11 22 but we
are responsible that that it is that as
well so the primary surplus when the
target was 3.8 is for this year so it is
a reasonable primary surplus the problem
is that with minus 1 percent growth and
inflation lies close to zero you will
need seven percent to keep the dead
stable so this is buddy what the
disappearance of growth does to you when
when when you have a high high debt so
this is the situation today with so this
quarter here the 1st quarter of 2013
will be the eighth eighth consecutive
quarter of negative growth and the minus
one DMF is forecasting for the year
means another two years of negative
growth and maybe zero turning around at
the end at the end of the year so there
was a if you look back in history 20
years back there is one episode which is
reminiscent of what what happened to
hear of course in an international
environment that was very different in
the between 1991 and 1998 when Italy had
to meet the criteria mastery criteria to
join to join the Europe there was also a
very large increase improvement in
in the fiscal position which amounted to
six percent of GDP the composition was
more or less similar was seventy percent
higher taxes thirty percent lower
spending what was the outcome of that
similar that similar physical correction
in 1993 so the correction was announced
in September 92 just the month after the
lira was forced out of the European
monetary system which was at the time
the arrangement linking the various
currencies to the deutsche mark in 1993
private consumption fell three percent
of the consumption for those of you who
are not economy is a very stable value
Larry if only real concern by 3% happens
once in a I'd know half a century but
not only what this war is not only a
drop in consumption therefore in output
in 93 but if you look at the following
years and you look at the deviation of
consumption in Italy from the average of
the euro 12 in from 94 to 99 we were
online so the deviation was zero but
because the meantime with the valued
fifty percent because after we left erm
it aleera went down a lot but the moment
we join the euro the memory of that
fiscal adjustment probably me so it's
hard to prove but the out can be that
consumption was half percent below the
average of the euro area for for a
number of year thereafter so there was a
long memory of the tax based fiscal
correction of those years not always
negative there is one thing that is
there is positive what has been done one
important imbalance was corrected so the
problem the impact on the budget of
aging which is pensions and health care
has been said essentially to zero so
this is a is the IM
estimate of the net present value in the
coming 40 years so how much it will cost
in the coming 40 years to take care of
pensions and in health care for
population discounted at some it's an
interest rate you see there are contact
the US that have a lot of work to do so
the IMF estimate of impact is almost two
hundred percent of GDP so this is the
sum of course over 40 years of what it
would cost what the impact will be on
the federal of US federal budget of
aging in the coming fold here's a very
large number and is that Italy is
happily down here so the arrow here is
on Japan I meant to be a little in a
sorry if which there is something but is
very small so this has been at least one
word that is that is out oh and this is
a result of the pension and health
reform done in the 90s and then repeat
it over and over again until the last
pension reform that Mario Monti did
exactly a year ago so the quest if if
I've convinced you I don't know if I
have that when you have high debt if you
don't grow you are in trouble the issue
is why has Italy stopped growing because
I think you have to ask why you have
stopped growing before asking what you
have to do to to grow and I think there
are we can have a very different views
but at least I think there are three
which are non mutual exclusive
possibilities for why growth has has
stopped one is the size of the public
sector which has increased and with an
increase the size of the public sector
the tax revenue as a share of GDP we've
seen has gone to fifty percent and this
doesn't help
private demand but i want to emphasize
not only taxes but the size of a private
sector because if the private sector is
big there is no way you can reduce taxes
the second one is the euro which could
be a factor in in quietly stop growing
and the other one is a less obvious
thing which I want to draw your
attention in a minute which is the
failed transition from a phase where a
country grows through imitation to a
phase where a country grows through
innovation what they call the Japanese
syndrome because it's a syndrome that
makes Italy very similar in this sense
to to Japan so let's go through them one
by one so the size of the public sector
so in Italy is not the largest public
sector in the euro area Frances larger
of course then the next question is how
effective it is because sweetie sweetie
they're also a large public sector but
the efficiency of the Swedish public
sector may be different between Italy
and France I'm not sure anyway we are
around fifty percent I put the numbers
for Frankfurt Germany here because we
often discuss the fact that German is
doing so well John is so different and
we have to remember that under
Chancellor Schroeder who may be because
of this lost the election was not real
acted journey with a lot of work not
only through the heart reform in
changing the rules of labor market but
also in shrinking the public sector so
expenditure which is a measure public
spent with a measure of the side the
public sector went down five percent of
GDP between 96 and actually six percent
between 96 and 97 so this is part curl
and path the beginning of Schroeder and
then went up a bit in the crisis but
only one percent which is so Germany did
a lot of work in reducing the size of
the public sector and there
reducing the pressure of taxes on the
economy and these numbers are important
because it's not only labor market from
Germany did a lot also in the size of
private sector and the observation is
here that maybe the country's down below
could do the same thing that high taxes
are not good for for growth so that was
the side the public sector private
sector public sector the second is the
euro so this is what happened to unit
labor costs so the cost per unit the
cost of labor per unit of output setting
these four countries Germany France
Spain in Italy to a hundred when the
Eurostar in 99 and running to last two
last year and they're not enormously
different I mean what is different here
is Germany which actually reduced unit
labor costs through wage moderation and
increasing productivity and then only
let labor costs increase a bit during
the Christ and the increase in labor
costs is because Germany has kept as you
the system of dividing in the Chrysler
rather than in allowing firms to lay
workers to reduce hours worked so as to
keep workers on the payroll but at lower
our the new series because the unit
labor costs increase but we're still
miles below below these countries there
another interesting thing in this graph
that Spain which of course was the
fastest running has has shifted so unit
labor costs in Spain are falling there
now below if you were to increase this
is not there below friends in Italy so
Spain is doing an adjustment force
coming from from a very high level so
maybe part of the reason Italy is not
growing is
that unit labor costs have increased a
lot and competitiveness of the economy
has has fallen why have unit labor costs
increased so this is an attempt to
divide and I apologize for Italian the
increasingly because in two component
this is our lily hourly labor
productivity and this is total factor
productivity total factor productivity
is more worrisome so hourly labor
productivity essentially remains flat
you would expect any in an increase
productivity increases and it increased
in all countries except italy even in
spain our liberal productivity what was
increasingly but what is more war is a
total factor productivity which for the
layman is how efficient the countries to
use the capital it has and the labor it
has a fee to put them together
efficiently this has been has been
falling throughout the century since we
joined the euro to the vertical tivities
increasing and this is the war isn't
things it tells something where
countries no longer able to use
efficiently the resources it has why is
tfp solo so one possibility has been
discussed a lot in Italy is that we are
in the wrong sectors we are in the wrong
in the wrong place so this nexus eyes
that the Bank of Italy has done trying
to recompute Italian dasa production
using not restructured composition by
industry of Italy which is the black
line but in the red and green line using
the comp what Italy has produced had the
output of Italian industry had the same
structure as the output in in france in
france and germany no big difference
right it's had we been friends probably
output of being a slightly higher but
the
no biggie which means it's not really
the composites that we are in the we are
in the wrong in the wrong sector this
thing tells a lot this is a nice graph
from Fabiano's Coverity who is an
economist at lewis in in rome and what's
a piano has done has computed the
variance of profits and productivity
across italian firm so he has taken
microdata for individual firms and look
what the variance show how dispersed
profits and productivity are across
firms from 1990 up to today and what is
interesting here is that from the start
of the euro the variance in jumps up
increased a lot so forget about the
level in the level is country-specific
but the fact the variance jumps up a lot
a fabulous interpretation of this of
this graph is that Italian firms have
really divided are much more different
from one another today than they were 20
years ago and by look a bit more curve
carefully the data he identified
essentially two groups of firms there is
one group of firm that are the firmware
productivity is increasing and profits
are increasing these are firm that use
the euro as an occasion to restructure
they understood that easy the valuation
no longer an option to be competitive in
international markets you had to get
your act together raise productivity and
profits and this did a lot and these are
the firm that are exporting then you
have a lot a different bunch of him who
did almost not invested productivity and
profits were falling and this is the
explanation for why the variance within
this blue of this firms this is the
universe of offer I think above a
minimum amount of workers is going up
and this increase movies tell the story
well you tell my students is stop
looking at the averages the averages for
Italy becoming increasingly meaningless
but not as you would think the average
between the North and the South is not a
regional difference of those there are
regional differences the difference
because between those firms that are
exposed international competitions that
are exporters and those from that only
sell the domestic market they are
protected internally from all sort of
laws that protect them and that cancer
but they should leave the market but
they survive with a low profit or
productivity because they are protects
of the average is 0 but 0 is an average
of plus 10 and mine and minus 10 and one
another in another element of this is it
is a country has essentially in almost
balanced trade balance so the trade is
has recently move a little bit into
deficit but on balustrade is balanced
and because Italy doesn't produce a drop
of oil or of gas all the energy that is
used in the country is paid for by the
by this firm that are that are exporter
so is it allows the trade balance to be
back so it's important to realize that
this graph capture the idea the very two
different countries those that are that
have used the euro to become productive
to increase to increase productivity and
profits there and they export typically
eighty percent of their output and those
were is that domestic oriented they
should leave the market and they don't
because they Deborah and I think this
tells a lot about about why the country
has stopped growing because the
difference between these two groups of a
firm's has increased a lot so there is a
if you think about the scan through
these two groups of firms there is an
interesting observation than by three
economists one of them at the New York
Fed palapa Zen tea and they make an
interesting observation the same if you
have a country like which has a problem
of loss of competitive like this year
the two ways to do the adjustment there
is a tough way which is to reduce
nominal wages because now under if it's
exchanges you have to reduce nominal
wages or raise increase productivity
fast and Germany which is
but there is another way you can adjust
and the other way you can adjust which
is as I say not as dramatic is to allow
those firm that are unproductive to exit
the market and al are productive firms
to come in to change the composition of
output raising the output of those
productive further maybe allowing them
to sell also on the domestic market and
what the show is i think is interesting
that changing the composition of firms
is not a complete cept but goes a long
way to substitute for a cut in nominal
wages which instead what you need to do
if the composition of output is is is
fixed and this I think is is the problem
that this reallocation of output from
the unproductive sector of the economy
to the productive sector of the economy
is difficult if you want is not such a
bad situation because if you did not
have the productive set of the sector of
the economy if zero was the mean but
zero is also for everybody you've been
trouble right now you have a part which
is productive you have to allow this
part of the economy to increase and to
shrink the other but if you do this I
think there is a future so there is a
relatively easy future the issue is how
to do it there are other problem so this
is a an interesting it looks at the
percentage of firm the teryx but this is
to tell you that it is not for those
firm that are productive it is not a
comparative competitiveness problem so
this is the percent of firms exporting
to selected markets abroad so this here
the firm that are exported to china and
india is prone to other asian countries
with us and canada and these are the
countries so if you look at this look at
the last column you see that
thirty-seven percent of german firms a
bit more than one out of three is able
to export to the US and canada
thirty-two percent in france thirty
percent in italy so is not the italian
firms because wax but because they are
uncompetitive are no longer
able to go there the goal are there more
or less like France and German firms
well Spanish from only eighteen percent
go to the US but because Italians firms
are typically very small if you go to
the US is easy right everybody speaks
English going to US and canada is easy
but you have to go to the rest of asia
say to Vietnam or to Thailand to market
that are growing fast then if you're a
small firm in Veneto it's very difficult
to go to Tyler and you see while
twenty-six percent of German firms are
exporting to the rest of Asia only
fourteen percent actually less than in
Spain so this is to say that even in
that part of the economy that is able to
export the size of the firm's and we'll
get a moment to what this size is so
small it's a it's a limitation to the
ability to to export so why the size is
smaller with anything now we're talking
about the productive part of the economy
lettuce idea productive but most of
these are of this productive firms their
family owned 85.6 person mr owned by
what individual code in private
companies but this is not very
differently in german the private
companies are ninety percent so it's
actually more what is war ism in italy
is that the management is all in-house
so sixty-six percent of the management
of this private health companies is the
family and matches your kids are
wonderful is never a good idea to let
your your company be around by your can
you see germany has ninety percent of
the german companies are privately held
but only twenty-eight percent have
domestic home family management and this
is is a problem because if you if you
want the management to be to be your son
or your daughter or your nephew or your
your son-in-law you're not going to grow
to grow very fast and this is one of the
issues why I think this has to do with
probably with culture before even think
about financial not but this is one big
issue in in why firms are small and firm
big small has the drawback that I
mentioned just above so this was I'm
almost done this was to talk about the
productive path which had problem of its
own so remember we said going back to
the this Kivar de Graaff we want to
eliminate these big variants you want to
to get rid of the imprudent productive
firms and to increase the room of the
reproductive ones why doesn't doesn't
this happen well because economics works
if you are these are the profit margins
in Italy compared to the rest of you row
area so if you're in the service sector
and the service sector is typically all
domestic your profit margins are sixty
percent in Italy they're high that they
are highly manufacturing even in in the
rest of your elbow 35% they are almost
half of Italy if you're in the
manufacturing do exactly like the URL
you have a twenty percent margin which
is you can live with but it certainly
small so if you are an entrepreneur and
you have you decide where to invest this
is exactly where to invest so you look
at families like famous families in the
north is that used to produce the sweat
that many of you are wearing tonight
what you do you close down or you scale
down your sweater company and you enter
in telecoms in highways in services
where your profit margins why the profit
margin is big because these are highly
protected industries where if Mike and I
would want to enter to get partly sixty
percent it'd be pretty hard and this
says old if you another important area
for example all of
the services provided by city's waste
disposal what our electricity all the
service of the cities provide are
typically provided by come visit our fee
at least 51-percent owned by the city so
these are areas where you would like to
expand but you cannot because because
the the city would not reduce its
presence as a shareholder of this
company so this tells you why did
shifting capital from the unproductive
to the productive part of the economy
which should mean making services more
productive is difficult because they are
high did I call this profit margin but
these are really rights right because
sixty percent is around our high to to
eliminate Y easily it's not growing so
possibility number three this is
completely different maybe I don't know
if it's completely wrong but I'm
fascinated by a paper by the national
glow of a mighty Philip Philip a yahoo
is at Harvard and fabric totally
birthday in Zurich which was published a
few years ago and they have I think a
very interesting idea about why
countries grow fast and then and then
don't grow which may be all of us who
studied growth theory would find it
relatively easy but I think it goes a
long way into understanding why Japan
has stopped growing beyond the financial
crisis and maybe why Italy has stopped
growing so countries when they are far
away from the technological frontier
growing is easy right think of Italy in
the nineteen fifty 50s and 60s mr.
agnelli would come to the u.s. learn how
you produce cars from from Ford or from
GM go back to Torino and produce cars
typically the design was better than in
Detroit the cars would also run better
like the toyota cars Woodrow
but they were cars right so the
technology was a West technology then it
was improved upon but there was no real
no real innovation it was mostly
intelligent imitation all the things is
called white goat it was a big industry
in Italy in the 60s refrigerators
kitchen the thing was all US technology
again the design was infinitely better
if done by Genesee then bye-bye view
correspond US company but the technology
was resting on and if you think about
Japan a law is not all I mean this is
making life simple but but if you think
a lot of the technological advances in
the 80s in Japan in electronics the
technology was really developed in the
US and then the Japanese was was very
good at doing the the technical exercise
better than us but no real or Allah
certainly not enormous innovation then
you arrived at the technological
frontier and then you have to start
winner it but there's nothing more you
can imitate and then life gets difficult
why because the institutions that are
good in the face of imitation are no
longer the good ones when you have to
innovate so in the face of imitation you
need large companies for example the
state on companies theory which was this
big state on conglomerate in Italy or
meat industry ministry in Japan the Big
Bang the close connection between banks
and industry very stable management in
the face of mutation is good right you
want to have a big factory a guy there
telling you have to do this and this and
what and watching their to do it right
you don't have to admit you never grow
apple or another comp like this in a in
a country where you are good at
imitating why because you're a large
bank will never finance steve job in his
basement and the japanese or italian
structure windows in the 50s and 60s is
not good for the innovation so one i
think what this is not i mean this in
intuition that these three economies
have everything is very interesting
intuition that should be stunned
more but I think that one of these where
this country stopped is because they
were unable to check whether you are
enabled because when you when you build
this big institution that are crucial in
limitation phase you don't just
dismantle them from from the day to the
next don't just dis mental the large
banks the large conglomerate it takes
they become very powerful they have
political links they stay there long
after they have survived their
usefulness and this I think is part of
what is happening in Israel partly
difficulty in relocating capital from
the unproductive to the productive part
of economy so and I'm done so what
prevents the relocation I think politics
is central because if you had to
reallocate capital you have really
interesting in the economy and society
that has to add that have to be changed
and if you look and if I should do this
but this we're five days ahead of the
elections i think it's we can do this
the if you look at the two big parties
that are competing in the italian
election unfortunately in my view none
of them has an incentive to reallocate
capital from the unproductive to the
productive part of the economy the PDL
the center-right as a culture which
couldn't be further away from
competition if you think the leader of
the of the center-right has been a
wonderful entrepreneur there's no doubt
about that but in in three sector that
are typically protected sector he start
in a real estate continued in the media
and insurance so if you think of three
sectors are protected regulated we're
good relation with the governor crucial
those are real estate insurance and
media so he's not the person has ever
been opened or exposed to international
completo he doesn't understand it
because they have been very successful
and why should I think about how
difficult it is to export to China so
this is not a part of the political
spectrum where you
you you will find a lot of enthusiasts
and if you look at the composition of
the members of parliament for the
centre-right both those who were in
Parliament until last week and will be
in Parliament as of next week I guess I
think three out of five of them are
lawyers so you're not going to open up
the legal profession which one of the
geishas in Italy three out of five
members of parliament of this part are
lawyers on the other side you have the
Democratic Party which has a problem
with the necrotic party relies for its
support on the unions and the union's
today essentially represent either
retired workers for example ggl the
biggest tuna which represents the left
more than fifty percent of the members
of this union are retired worker so it
is all almost surprised he was able to
do this big pension reform with a
powerful Union that is representing
retired workers while because the
patient was was was not most with a lot
done by hitting the young people and not
the other end the unit is very strong in
incumbent firms preside in those firm it
would like to to move out of the market
to make to make room for the new
entrance which could shift the balance
so this may not be a very promising view
of the election but my view is that this
account that can really do it it is
possible to to stop the decline so to
stop what we saw in the first graph but
you really and ask yourself every
different investors assume one with an
investor as if who is winning the battle
between the productive part and
productive part which so metrocard know
the trade balance is zero ether it
doesn't borrow from the rest of the
world but does but doesn't grow because
so far the unproductive part is
has been the stronger one I stopped here
but now we can discuss for as long as
you can as you want